America's Got Talent auditions are
underway as the returning judges prepare
to get their smiles on with new hosts
Tyra Banks it's very cool and it
immediately feels like a family to Tyra
signed up for the gig after Nick Cannon
announced in February he's leaving the
NBC competition show I didn't know that
Nick wasn't going to be on the show I'd
shot about two or three weeks before we
started filming the news came as a bit
of a shock for judge and executive
producer Simon Cowell's after one day we
get a phone call Tyra Banks wants to
meet I thought I'd been wound up to
girls with you
Tyra has some very expensive shoes to
fill when Nick came at me how she
stacking up oh I think she knows shoes
she knows style she knows fashion she
knows poise she is the consummate
professional girls rule now with three
girls against two boys were so used to
seeing Nick coming onto the stage but I
have to say she fit right in there she's
funny she gets it I think she's having a
good time
I mean how exciting is it to be part of
the AGD family it's very cool and it
immediately feels like a family too with
my girl Heidi being here and then Simon
just being papa and embracing and saying
you just do you Dottie I had you here
for you
you